I am the grandson of immigrants from
Japan to Glenn to America I was four
years old when Pearl Harbor was bombed
on December 7 1941 by Japan and
overnight the world was plunged into a
world
my brother and I were in the living room
looking out the front window and we saw
two soldiers marching up our driveway
they carried bayonets on their rifle
they stomped up the front porch and
banged on the door my father answered it
and the soldiers ordered us out of our
home we were taken from our home and
loaded onto train cars with other
Japanese American families there were
guards stationed at both ends of each
car as if we were criminals we were
taken on that train for four days and
three nights to the swamps of Arkansas I
still remember the barbed wire fence
that confined me
I remember the tall sentry tower with
the machine guns pointed at us I
remember the searchlight that followed
me when I made the night runs from my
barrack to the latrine when the war
ended we were released and given a
one-way ticket to anywhere in the United
States my parents decided to go back
home to Los Angeles but Los Angeles was
not a welcoming place everything had
been taken from us and the hostility was
intense
my parents worked hard to get back on
their feet
ultimately they were able to get the
capital together to buy a 3-bedroom home
in a nice neighborhood and I was a
teenager and I became very curious about
my childhood imprisonment and so I
engaged my father after dinner in long
sometimes heated conversations he told
me that our democracy is a people's
democracy and it can be as great as a
people can be but it is also as fallible
as people are
he told me that American democracy is
vitally dependent on good people who
cherish the ideals of our system and
actively engage in the process of making
our democracy work